that's how I get in the shot talking
about
[Music]
[Music]
well hello reject nation it's Greg Alba
here and it's Kyle and hi element for
the fan Theory Channel so we've been
invited to participate in the cgb
cinemas when apart haunted theater
experience we're gonna take a look
inside the theater the first time ever
where cg b is gonna be doing a haunted
Halloween experience we're turning into
a sort of Wonderland it's gonna be
complete with like some spooky
decorations there's supposedly gonna be
some like spooky noises in there too and
the thing I'm most excited for is the
delicious Halloween themed menu because
and supposedly on the weekends and I
think tonight - after 7:00 p.m. who's
gonna be like wandering clowns and
scares and zombies so they're going full
out haunted experience today so we're
gonna take a look inside the theater and
then we're actually gonna check out the
40x experience Kyle and I have never
done a 40 X I hear they have another
amazing 40 X experience but let's take a
look inside the theater together guys hi
Kyle follow me
[Music]
exactly
never been to a movie theater
[Music]
it's cool like Halloween
[Music]
or have their makeup
I love how decked out the scene is never
seen a theater news such a crazy like
Halloween
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're gonna try out the 40x experience
we've never done a for DXi here this is
one of the best I'm super super super
excited are you excited I'm freaking
thrilled everybody they told us some
cool things about it man I'm pretty
excited
oh you feel that it says get your arms
it's like gunshots gets like the lower
back and then the upper part of your
back
oh my
[Music]
[Music]
it doesn't feel like you could feel the
vibration yeah yeah underneath like
instantons different specific area yeah
and it's subtle too like some of its
like it's all there there's a lot of
overall all right so we just experienced
Blade Runner 2049 on for DX you saw this
what you see this again Dolby Digital
y'all be digital I saw it in IMAX and we
both really enjoyed the hell out of the
movie we thought it was already great we
didn't know how much more immersive 4dx
would really be it truly is a much more
immersive experience the sound is so
much better than even you could imagine
and then the subtle movements and the
chairs the way the vibrations all work
they affect different parts of this big
chair yeah and they're not all the same
vibration don't think like a playstation
controller they're all a different type
of vibration depending on what the sound
design is what the effect is if it's a
heat it rocks a lot more if it's a
subtle little pad or something you can
feel those little yes very subtly like
it over there and if it's like a shock
you feel like it feels like a little
like back massage is pretty cool and
it's different parts of the body from
your legs here back and machinery and
everything it's all like fluid it's just
you feel it like you're really
experiencing it you know what tripped me
out was when the flying shots Oh feels
like you're like whoa we have the subtle
changes at the chair moving forward and
backwards yeah but the shot makes you to
feel like you're moving along with the
flying vehicle pretty crazy
yeah it's it's the coolest experience it
it makes you feel like you're on a ride
yeah it did feel kind of like those
Simpsons rides back to the future yeah
yeah and also of course like the other
great effects like when it's windy in a
scene there's this great wind effect
does it feel like a sea is blowing on
you it's just this cool it feels like
real wind and when it rains you feel the
boils of mist it crazy feels like you're
really you know what you're not getting
soaked yet it feels like you're actually
in the middle of a rainstorm yes that's
the coolest one of the things that I was
a little concerned about whether it
would pull me out or not but it actually
worked a lot was the smoked effect when
the smoke effect happened on the screen
like when Ryan Gosling walks into a fog
it wasn't distracting if anything
did make it feel a lot more real it's
pretty freakin cool man it made the
experience more immersive for a film
attorney his greatest Blade Runner and
after going on imax he would think
nothing could top it but I really
thought this topic
yeah I agree 100% it was such a great
experience for me and I would do it a
hundred times over it's the time I've
been waiting the most for food all right
Kyle well let's have some Halloween
munchies right now oh you're gonna have
your Betty pepperoni pizza and I'm gonna
have my Franken finger hot dog so is my
witch's brew there are actual bats cut
into the cheese it's the coolest whoa
hey changing color candy corn beverage
chip
oh honey look at the like Halloween
sprinkles round of salt yeah yeah it's
really good Cheers
that's tasty test tastes like candy it's
like a candy alcoholic drink that's
awesome way better than candy corn
Franken finger hot dog seriously check
that out something bad on it
hello crap I was expecting it just to be
pizza this is not just pizza it's really
amazing oh there's like stuff stuff
underneath the feet something
I'll go check the cd-rom it's amazing
there's a good Billy like there's up
there
[Laughter]